[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it was going on everybody first we feet
I'm Sean Evans and today I'm joined by
link and rest together
the rhett and Link yeah and you've
probably known good mythical morning you
can catch them on rhett and Link buddy
system on YouTube red and they're also
two of the most prolific taste testers
on YouTube is that about better
characterization we've we've eaten a lot
of things I try not to taste it while
I'm eating it well today we are going to
taste and we're going to take to the max
we're doing a little hot one offseason
training now usually when we do this
offseason training I have my friend
chili Klaus come in and we just pop a
reaper we just mail it in we just phone
in the whole show and we just chalk it
up to some sort of language barrier I
think it's a little bit poor hook them
has been an avian discussion but today
we're a little more intellectually
driven because we're going to do a game
of trivia believing the best about us
well this is like very college professor
so then the stakes are high because if
you miss a question if you get an answer
wrong you have to take a keeping healthy
fork full of the spiciest curry in the
world but first an awkward segue to the
kitchen so that we know what the hell
we're eating for lunch
model carry which is decisive cutting
the one in England a stock has a dead
where they would actually click for
chili pepper to anybody and make it
spicy somebody really is a range uncle
father's way to go so you guys have
eaten Carolina Reapers before I remember
12 hours later I was in the fetal
position on the floor when we did the
folly renewal we took it to the next
level we created a curry which is the
slices that inverse habaneros like chili
powder and then can the ghost pepper
them it working in from Baca bed that's
where I found the can Landry bro the
first time he's applying Reaper mass to
us
I have chills I'm sweating and then it
goes right through my body over the top
of my head and everything's like
twisting and contracting when we're
actually making the fog we advise the
hooks to where gas loss it can actually
really choke
[Music]
here's what's on the table we have
vindaloo which some people say is the
hottest curry that they've ever had
didn't go to get the hottest curry that
everyone else has had we came to get the
hottest curry ever the way the game
works we have 10 trivia questions I'm
not privy to them I don't know what they
are I have no idea I could end up taking
ten bites here multiple choice you can
play along at home you get an answer
wrong you take a big spoonful or a big
fork full of fall and then we fall to
the ground I think I don't know if there
are any winners here hmm all right
without further ado yeah hey this is a
question number one where does fall
curry originated from a Bangalore India
B Dhaka Bangladesh C Birmingham England
one two three good thing the correct
answer is C Oh Oh kidding me what is one
of the rules here I just say is like a
fork theologist them right
oh look there's it there's a carrot that
should that'll help that'll save you
little bit huh send it home
[Music]
yeah go there you go when I eat things
that are hot film it's gonna be okay
especially if you keep getting up right
number two where does the Carolina
Reaper clock in on the Scoville scale a
1.4 million units be 2.2 million units C
3.1 million units I feel like I know
this basic criteria speed alright we're
gonna be alright it's going to be
alright we're going to be alright today
is going to be alright
Nora number three a restaurant in
Grantham England claims its wood or fall
curry is the spiciest in the world which
peppers business dish contains a
Carolina Reapers see Trinidad Moruga
scorpion see naga infinity chili hey the
correct answer is whoa whoa whoa all
right
I'm hoping the first one is the toughest
I'm gonna go with your move where I just
I pad it with a little bit what do you
guys do whatever you want you over there
and that it was the right uh-oh it's
really opening up and sign it don't slow
down for it you're making us all bad
customer my good night little crazy you
know I want to but I'm not going to
follow suit
I'm what link is doing when I lose
income it's your show on our show we
think it they get then we shake it
oh you cross stewards over again Oh
[Music]
you got that down real fast you cute not
really a piece of chicken home that was
my move like that was strategic oh I
usually have a trash can you buy - I
would advise you to ask somebody to get
one get a cab number for taxation the
active ingredient in chili peppers also
has a number of medicinal purposes which
of the following is not one of them a
relieving stomach pain be restoring
eyesight see treating her teeth Wow
the hell of a trivia question trainees
stomach pain that seemed so ridiculous
that it has to be somewhat true come on
we gotta get him eating this stuff one
two three we see a system changes every
season the correct answer is oh we have
a can give this a chewer that's my
problem
so should you alright okay there it is
there we go we've got that out of the
restroom I don't know if this will work
I'm gonna make it like it's like a
filling I'm gonna wrap it are you gonna
you gonna burrito oh but it in bread now
if I'm going to try to do that's a good
idea
I feel like this is yeah I feel like
this is a really good idea right here
ah you got it man no barf bucket for you
you don't need that bark like it's right
there next to your leg the one that you
could barf into if you needed to you
don't need that
oh okay I'll tell you
whew whatever you do get your first bite
Oh imma be I'm gonna bury my want to be
relieved number five after successfully
completing brick lane curry house fall
curry challenge one to customers when a
three car for light be a free beer see
$100 cash $100 you can lose a lot of
money real fast doing that oh but not
everybody drink oh please please leave
City of God Lila [ __ ] huh yeah I
don't know
one two three three and with a hundred
bucks
Zoe beer one crack the answer is B thank
you
that made more hot a lot it didn't make
more thick oh I get to fit this without
to feel good did not have to it's so so
good to be me right now except for the
me that I was the last three times I had
to eat that stuff
cheers my man he's well down the highway
but you're just you're just getting on
the on-ramp welcome to the party rut you
follow it all right
[Music]
he does this Venn thing I'm telling my
brain that is not happening okay number
six on November 2013 the Carolina Reaper
won the Guinness World Record for the
world's hottest pepper a title it still
holds to this day what pepper did the
Reaper dethrone a the Trinidad Moruga
scorpion be the seventh pot primo see
the naga vibrant it's really good hot
now ha yeah hey scorpion Hey
please be roasted correct answers hey
did you guys we all got it okay good so
right there number seven in 2001 British
Foreign Secretary Robin Cook declared
this curry a true British nationals in a
chicken vindaloo be chicken tikka masala
see chicken jalfrezi right now I'm kind
of like doing that bad student in high
school thing becomes like oh yeah yeah
yes I'm doing like you're playing to
psychology
one two three
Setrakian three see ya yo man yo what's
up hey I'm getting a little I'm getting
a little a little high from it yeah get
a nice cut of meat there all right
wait Sean Paul Tonko over here yeah yes
okay
little nose run you're feeling you still
don't like your own you got on top of it
clutch gently Kanye West once ordered
takeout from the British Raj forcing the
restaurant make a delivery from Wales to
New York City for $3,900 how did the
restaurant transport the food a by
private jet B by aircraft carrier C by
helicopter I don't even want to write my
answer because I know that it's probably
going to be wrong have to pee a little
bit is that because of the curtain is up
just because I feel a little bit resist
the temptation to pee in your own mouth
okay trust me three two one
Hey I knew it except slow Transpo
okay you can't fly a helicopter across
an ocean the correct answer is C so no
Kanye you can't do that you can't get a
helicopter across the ocean lettuce like
a black hawk and you are adjusting to
obvious bacteria I'm like what and then
game was helicopter I'm like in a
helicopter get across the Atlantic if it
can it has to be the answer that's my
math I did it my head where's the Oh God
I wrap this bad boy up everybody's going
with the with the very smart we
regretted not we did we're on to
something here
all right come on thank you
[Music]
it's not on the gum yeah
fireball it is so oddly satisfying to be
the one person naughty I mean if my body
don't want to expect this I think the
burrito really helped I just see quickly
I don't know why I have to see quickly
[Music]
telecom number 9 which celebrity was
forced to apologize after calling Perry
disgusting
in 2012 a Rihanna be Donald Trump see
Kim Kardashian was whether Kanye brought
across and the helicopter then we're
together in Queens well like I don't
really we should start working together
you're not million competition like when
you really break it down like when she
realizes because we're very stupid but
first off I'm stupid you have to be to
be like oh this will be a good [ __ ]
video not Donald Trump he doesn't call
it oh they're not doesn't apologize your
honor akin with Rihanna Rihanna I love
spicy food right I feel like Rihanna
she's gonna Caribbean yeah I don't think
that she was it this is Kim guy is a
very can I hear we are bending the will
of this show we are okay thanks yeah
very know I would be I so don't even
read it is it Kim K Kim Carter we didn't
go
we beat the system right yes no one's
watching the video anymore question
number 10 ghost peppers some of the
hottest Chili's in the world are used
for this unique purpose in northeastern
India a to keep elephants from
destroying homes be to punish convicted
criminals see to treat hypothermia we
can't see no the last one nobody's got
to go down with the plane okay how do
you are - well cheap
all right well mochi I don't think it's
the prison I also don't think it's the
elephant you like I might nail this one
then if I do I owe a very special
shout-out to somebody hello this baby
elephant how do we know that because we
didn't dare leave I guess we're gonna do
dry wine so here's I invited you guys
one time I was talking to chili Klaus
and this is the first time we've met
yeah but I already feel like we're
friends
I feel like you told me an anecdote
similar to that right and they usually
India to keep it open system in the
jungle in my head like through the
sauces that just went was something
about the elephants was something about
the farmland it was something like
there's not you're so sensitive and so
like when they eat the peppers it's like
a scarecrow scarecrows and you know so
little bit even just the closer's that's
like so like whoa I don't want to mess
with this area because the peppers are
so hot I got all pretty good guys I only
have two it's all here now it's a it's a
bubbling cauldron of hotness I don't
feel good I can only imagine how you're
feeling right now it feels like a car
crash your eyes are like so why because
that's that's - I'm getting that like
sort of that Molly ripoff the hot sauce
do editing that's also what's going on
you got a good animal right now like
your parents might you need to punch
it's not rated all right so obviously we
got to subscribe good mythical morning
on the youtubes on the YouTube what
funny system water climate zone is free
and then you already know what it is hot
one season three coming at you next week
or later this month we're possibly
sometime in the future but definitely so
this first one is sriracha you know
about sriracha dresses no big deal no
big deal
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans if you
liked the video maybe meet us halfway
throw us a subscribe if you didn't like
the video don't subscribe I don't want
you I don't want you in the tent but if
you liked the video subscribe thank you
very much I appreciate you I love you
more than a friend